a fourteen-year-old from California is
America's new top young scientist the
eighth grader created a nanoparticle
liquid bandage to replace antibiotics
sure I could have done that
she beat nine other finalists and
hundreds of students who submitted ideas
the 3m young scientist challenge is held
every year in st. Paul Minnesota the
national competition encourages middle
schoolers to come up with projects to
tackle global problems
nicky Patti's got a behind-the-scenes
look at the competition and a special
tour of the 3m labs you will see only on
CBS this morning I flunked seventh grade
sciences
I'm a little overwhelmed but you turned
out okay I got a job I'd like to meet
these kids well it was humbling if
anything I actually got an A in science
and now after meeting these young kids
I'm wondering how that's possible these
budding scientists exhibited strong
scientific thinking curiosity and
creative ways to communicate their
findings all ten of the finalists blew
me away but only one could take home the
final prize America's 2019 top young
scientist is Cara fan Cara fan was named
America's top young scientist for 2019
snagging a $25,000 prize
I feel really shocked and surprised but
really excited at the same time this is
the now summer at me judges were
impressed by her nanoparticle liquid
bandage my project is important because
it reduces the overuse of antibiotics
after two days of mind twisting
challenges and working one-on-one with
world-renowned scientists more than
twice their age in a sort of spelling me
for science these 10 finalists beat
hundreds of their 5th to 8th grade peers
for the chance to present their final
projects in front of 3m and discovery
executives I would have a solar panel
Caroline couchley got second place
she created a sustainable train that she
says is safer and more efficient than
Elon Musk's Hyperloop 4 million children
develop asthma every year due to air
pollution from cars and trucks and there
are 11,000
every day so I want to prevent all this
from happening you want to make the air
we breathe
safer yeah I designed developed a new
Train idea that can use renewable energy
sources instead of fossil fuels so it
would help the environment that's pretty
impressive good thank you
first you input a gesture Faraz Tambo li
created a device that translates sign
language into voice and voice into sign
language when my dad was around my age
there was this kid and he always wanted
to play with my dad but since he was a
phonic he couldn't talk to my dad and
tell him that he just wanted to play
with him so my dad got scared and ran
away his competition video illustrates
his idea I thought why can't I translate
their only way of communication sign
language and started thinking of how to
recognize the hand and its gestures and
figure out the movement of the hand I
learned a lot more about programming and
how it works before their final
presentations that young scientists
toured three M's Innovation Center to
see some adult projects like this echo
free chamber what these young minds have
learned may be a lesson not just in
science but in life my takeaway from
this project is that if you work well
with other people's and great things
happens I'm proud of myself doing this
project was fun but I also just really
wanted to help the definite phonic so in
the future I don't have to think look
back and see that I've there's still a
problem in this world and though there's
only one middle schooler taking home the
title of America's top young scientist
they all leave winners what's the
takeaway from this experience for you
that I still won I was a finalist and I
made it this far so it's good that I put
the effort in and I didn't give up one
of the most impressive things to see was
that these kids were more interested in
making their projects a reality than
just winning they truly want to change
the world past winners have met the
president Benin featured in Forbes 30
under 30 list spoken before Khan
and given TED talks if these kids are
our future I'm pretty up there riding
Caroline Crowley's train uses a magnet
sign language translator is really
useful I want to put that into practice
any slackers there with potatoes or
baking soda volcano no slackers Caroline
said her mentors best advice was never
procrastinate yeah they can't drive but
they can certainly change the world I
love when you've complimented her and
she just said thank you
Elon Musk she wants a phone call okay
that could happen
thank you very much Nikki